(elegant music)
- [Interviewer] A quote from
Director Darren Aronofsky,
"One of my very first calls
was to my makeup artist, Adrien Morot,
'Can we do something that's
incredibly realistic?'"
- No pressure.
That's the first thing. (chuckles)
And then the next thing he said
is that, "Well, by the way,
we're gonna see him nude.
He's gonna have short sleeves.
He's gonna have short pants."
And we ended up having 12
weeks to build a makeup.
(elegant music)
- What a great chance to create
these two iconic characters,
well, one iconic character
and then the villain.
And then, really, the other
bit was Elvis's progression.
You know, the more Tom Parker
got his claws into Elvis,
it manifested in the way he looked
right through where he
sings "Unchained Melody"
several weeks before he passed away.
- [All] Yes!
- Every day was like,
I started in the night and
I finished in the night.
We had like 200 soldiers every day,
everyone with like wigs or
facial hair, dirt, teeth,
because we didn't want it to
have the white teeth anymore,
then marching to set,
basically to the battlefield (chuckling).
And what you have seen in front of camera,
it looked the same behind
the camera. (chuckling)
- Hey, bitches!
(machine gun reporting)
- [Interviewer] Certainly
one of the standout makeups
in the movie is The Penguin.
It's not a makeup.
It's a complete and utter transformation
of Colin Farrell.
- I looked at it at a
different perspective.
Matt Reeves had some ideas
about how he was a little bit like Fredo
from "The Godfather."
I said, "How can I incorporate
a Penguin in here?"
- I felt like it was kind of a culmination
of all the makeups that
Mike and I have done
and really using almost
every trick in the book.
(dramatic music)
- This movie was all about the women.
You see, there's very few men
in it actually, (chuckles)
and it's about their connection.
One of the main things that I
think about "Wakanda Forever"
is that it's a franchise
that could have been over,
because we lost our star.
What kind of movie gets a chance
to come back as a rebirth,
and we got that opportunity.
And that's the most beautiful thing.
(elegant music)